good morning John it's Wednesday as
someone brought up recently doing
Brotherhood 2.0 every Wednesday I would
perform a song so okay I'm going to if
you don't know John's book is coming out
tomorrow and so there are lots of very
important and very cool Paper Towns
related things going on right now
there's a new Twitter stream containing
lots of fake spoilers from Paper Towns
Kaleigh from five awesome girls baked
John a Paper Towns cake it's a Paper
Towns tacular day and tomorrow will be
the ultimate Paper Towns tacular day it
will be October 16th the official
release date of Paper Towns so today I
am in the studio recording a paper town
song I'm going to start playing that
song right now
several nerdfighters and I have all
recorded paper town songs we are making
a Paper Towns collaborative album oh my
god isn't that awesome and we're giving
it away for free but in order to get
different counts collaborative album you
have to prove your dedication to Paper
Towns and you have to do that in three
different ways you have to take a
picture of yourself with Paper Towns and
make it here MySpace or Facebook profile
picture make it your youtube profile
picture and make it every profile
picture you can dig lots of pictures of
yourself with Paper Towns put them in
very visible places so for example if
you happen to get a painting of a hot
blonde girl on a bikini in the jungle
this would be a really good sinner
screenshot for you on YouTube second
buddy Olga bookstore and if you haven't
purchased Paper Towns and then put
little notes in the book right like on
the first page by the dusk lap is the
best place but a little note may be
sticking up a little bit that says how
much you love Paper Towns if just a
little bit of astronomy to get more
people interested in Paper Towns people
maybe really like oh I don't know what
this is and then be like oh look a note
so it's like a blurb but way better
because it's from just a normal person
who liked the book instead of some book
reviewer who liked the book Bree comment
on this video and then send an email to
strike-slip at gmail calm saying that
you've done all of those things and will
give you access to the downloads of this
album in addition you'll be able to pay
$3 which is the cost of the creation and
shipping of the CD to get an actual hard
copy of the CD and my battery is dying
so I won't be able to finish this video
in the studio but I will finish it at
home their friends
I'm home now and this is on and I'm all
you know this is really important
presidential election but all I can
think about is Paper Towns basically
goes a great deal towards explaining how
much John and his relationship has
changed in the past couple of years her
downs coming out as like an event in my
life on the scale of buying my first
house and the freaking presidential
election the once more to give access to
the Paper Towns collaborative album you
must take a picture of yourself apipa
downs and how about as your myspace our
facebook and youtube profile icon you
can also blog about it if you want be
really extra awesome but little notes
talking about how much you like paper
towns inside of unsold copies of Paper
Towns at bookstores three tell me below
how excited you are about pic downs
coming out